whether you like it or not we use
numbers every day some numbers such as
the speed of sound are small and easy to
work with other numbers such as the
speed of light are much larger and
cumbersome to work with we can use
scientific notation to express these
large numbers in a much more manageable
format so we can write 299 million 792
458 meters per second as 3.0 times 10 to
the eighth meters per second correct
scientific notation requires that the
first term range in values that it is
greater than 1 but less than 10 and the
second term represents the power of 10
or order of magnitude by which we
multiply the first term
we can use the power of 10 as a tool in
making quick estimations when we do not
need or care for the exact value of a
number for example diameter of an atom
is approximately 10 to the power of
negative 12 meters the height of the
tree is approximately 10 to the power of
1 meters the diameter of the earth is
approximately 10 to the power of 7
meters the ability to use the power of
10 as an estimation tool can come in
handy every now and again like when
you're trying to guess the number of m
ms in a jar but is also an essential
skill in math and science especially
when dealing with what are known as
fermi problems fermi problems are named
after the physicist enrico fermi who was
famous for making rapid order of
magnitude estimations or rapid
estimations with seemingly little
available data fermi worked on the
manhattan project in developing the
atomic bomb and when it was tested at
the trinity site in 1945 fermi dropped a
few pieces of paper during the blast and
used the distance they traveled
backwards as they failed to estimate the
strength of the explosion as 10 kilotons
of tnt which is on the same order of
magnitude as the actual value of 20
kilotons one example of the classic
fermi estimation problems is to
determine how many piano tuners there
are in the city of chicago illinois
at first there seem to be so many
unknowns that the problem appears to be
unsolvable that is the perfect
application for a power of 10 estimation
as we don't need an exact answer an
estimation will work we can start by
determining how many people live in the
city of chicago we know that it is a
large city but we may be unsure about
exactly how many people live in the city
are there 1 million people 5 million
people
this is the point in the problem where
many people become frustrated with the
uncertainty but we can easily get
through this by using the power of 10.
we can estimate the magnitude of the
population of chicago as 10 to the power
of 6. while this doesn't tell us exactly
how many people live there it serves as
an accurate estimation for the actual
population of just under 3 million
people so if there are approximately 10
to the six people in chicago how many
pianos are there if we want to continue
dealing with orders of magnitude we can
either say that one out of 10 or 1 out
of 100 people on a piano given that our
estimate of the population includes
children adults we'll go with the latter
estimate which estimates that there are
approximately 10 to the fourth or 10 000
pianos in chicago
with this many pianos how many piano
tuners are there we could begin the
process of thinking about how often the
pianos are tuned how many pianos are
tuned in one day or how many days a
piano tuner works but that's not the
point of rapid estimation we instead
think in orders of magnitude and say
that a piano tuner tunes roughly 10 to
the second pianos in a given year which
is approximately a few hundred pianos
given our previous estimate of 10 to the
fourth pianos in chicago and the
estimate that each piano tuner can tune
10 to the second pianos each year we can
say that there are approximately 10 to
the second piano tuners in chicago now i
know what you must be thinking how can
all of these estimates produce a
reasonable answer well it's rather
simple in any fermi problem it is
assumed that the overestimates and
underestimates balance each other out
and produce an estimation that is
usually within one order of magnitude of
the actual answer in our case we can
confirm this by looking in the phone
book for the number of piano tuners
listed in chicago what do we find
81 pretty incredible given our order of
magnitude estimation but hey that's the
power of 10.
you